[Musique]
difficile de s'y retrouver au rayon des
poils poêlon un chaudron certains grands
magasins offrent jour après jour des
rabais de 25 50 voire jusqu'à 80%
exemple au kennedy center cette poêle en
fonte de drogues vendues au départ 150
dollars est réduite à 70 40 et les
métaux fer dans liquidation à 30 heures
ce qui nous a intrigués
c'est que nous avons trouvé au même
moment une autre poêle enfant tu devras
sa poignée différentes mais il est de la
même dimension 26 cm et avec le même
revêtement par contre son prix courant
était de 25 $ à la boutique star frites
le fabricant des deux produits pourquoi
cet écart de prix le prix des parts est
il juste sur le modèle du canadien terre
s'agit-il d'un véritable raz b ou d'une
stratégie pour nous faire acheter sur
toi celle ci s'est dès lors que les deux
ça c'est le change un peu les passeurs
de la poignée on peut changer certaines
propriétés qui justifie le prix plus
élevés ou le prix plus bas alors le
pauvre consommateur qui a pas tous ces
paramètres techniques lors puis qui a
pas les informations en main peut pas
comparer exactement et c'est cette zone
grise look très souvent les fabricants
et les détaillants ont utilisé nous
avons tenté d'obtenir les prix de vente
suggéré de la part des fabricants mais
sans succès tefal pas de réponse chez
staff rip on nous répond que la façon
dont les prix sont fixés et ajusté est à
la discrétion du client
[Musique]
selon jean roy doyen de l'école de
gestion de l'université de sherbrooke
certains manufacturiers et commerçants
profitent de cette confusion 75% si le
seul agassi ne claquez qu au kéké pas
comparable qu'on a réussi je vais
complètement avant qu'il
soit maintenant à 500 dollars au lieu de
ne pas certain que le compagnon d'anne
est le véritable raz b c'est vraiment un
produit de qualité pour notre eau des
menteurs ont bcp dans d'autres
circonstances ya des compagnies qui vont
monter artificiellement le prix puis on
veut redonner des forums mais parvenir à
prouver ça devant les tribunaux ça prend
vraiment des données des suivis et c'est
cette zone grise loc rod manufacturier
encore aujourd'hui utilisent pour aller
chercher une croissance des ventes de
façon générale
pas forcément on peut pas prétendre non
plus que le prix ordinaire est un pli x6
et polico selon maître sylvie de
bellefeuille la loi protège les
consommateurs au fédéral qu'au
provincial
grosso modo ce que la loi nous dit on en
parlera de maths est aussi simple que ça
le prix habituel doit donc être
véridique pour cela la loi fédérale
exige que le produit était vendu à ce
prix en grande quantité pendant une
période raisonnable ou vendus de bonne
foi à ce prix pendant une période
importante
le problème pour le consommateur sait
comment savoir c'est quoi le prix
régulier surtout quand les rabais sont
un cycle et puis on parle d'un rabais à
un autre de façon graduelle c'est facile
de perdre son latin tellement vrai une
belle pub parce qu'ici je sais pas si
vous voyez un autre un peu de côté mais
ces espèces de poissons profonds des
cinq peuples avec ouverte ils sont tous
fabriqués par tes fesses c'est 30 de
leurs prêts réguliers si on s'envoie ici
25 dollars mais cannes interprétant
qu'ils étaient 90 à laquelle l'otan
droit puis l'oeil vraiment à presque
identique ici on l'a 35 prêts réguliers
45 honnêtement pour l'impression que
c'est si différent que c'est que ça
justifie un écart de prix de 25 à 90 la
questionner sur tous ces écarts de prix
qui d une part nous répond que bien que
la conception et la dimension soient
semblables à des produits chez les
concurrents la vie va est un produit
exclusif avec des caractéristiques et
spécifications qui la distingue en
finalisant notre reportage on note que
la poêle vivant en question n'est plus
au rabais et canadiens tard indique
maintenant que son prix de base passe de
90 à 120 dollars soit une augmentation
de 33 % en quelques semaines seulement
le savoir vraiment le rôle du
consommateur de magasiner de vérifier
exactement d'une part c'est quoi son
besoin et à partir de là à faire des
comparaisons pas s'y trouver le meilleur
rapport qualité prix dans tout ça tenant
compte des spéciaux des circulaires pour
essayer le plus possible d'en avoir pour
son argent
autre exemple ce présentoir de batteries
cuisine sur les 30 modèles offerts 24
sont tous rêvaient ici des ensembles à
2000 $ côtoient des ensembles à 300
dollars selon jean droit c'est un truc
vieux comme le monde avant une des
approches marketing qu'on peut utiliser
l'eau c'est ce qu'on appelle le prix
maximum psychologique que les
consommateurs sont craints pays les
études démontrent comme par exemple je
prends d'analogie de notre sport
national qui est là ok ça va deux
présentoirs de patin si vous avez un
patin à 800 dollars ça va faire en sorte
que le pâté 1 400 dollars va se vendre
beaucoup mieux que si vous n'avez pas de
patin lyssandre soudainement le patin
catalan devient un incroyable rêver
qu'est-ce qui fait comme consommateur
qu'on est si attaché à ce pourcentage de
réduction nous en marketing on sait
qu'il ya un pourcentage en un an
populations qui sont toujours à la
recherche du rab et donc nos stratégies
de commercialisation sont au fait que si
vous avez 30 % des gens qui recherchent
un rabais et qu'on ne propose pas de
rabais les gens vont arrêter de venir
dans notre commerce donc tous les
commerçants samso et doivent proposer
des rabais donc on sait qu'on doit
annoncer des rabais tout au long de
l'année sinon on va perdre un
achalandage
bonne nouvelle le consommateur pour se
protéger au hac c'est maintenant a
tellement plus facilement l'information
qu'auparavant on est tous très capable
de prendre son téléphone et des gens
mais de faire une recherche aujourd'hui
pour voir quels sont les prix en
amérique du nord ou dans le monde pour
ce type de produit l'eau qui s'y
approche suffisamment je marche
simplement j'ai d'ailleurs un but ou 70%
je ne dois pas rater cette aubaine
j'économise mais exactement faut se
rappeler que la meilleure économie c'est
toujours de ne pas acheter quand on en a
pas besoin
ou quand même garder sans fin pour se
garder une petite gêne pas taille quand
on est enceinte elle compulsif à ce que
ce soit quand on voit une belle
étiquette de couleur soixante dix pour
cent de rabais ce que ça va attirer
notre regard et combien de fois comme
consommateur ça nous arrive d'acheter
quelque chose parce que s'étant soldés
finalement ça aboutit dans un fonds de
tiroir donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
magazines et de dijon
[Musique]
oui